are you extra sensitive to noise does it
affect you to be in a chaotic you wanna
you know I think it does yeah I have two
young children at home to now and so you
know when I walk into my house it's just
like this wall of noise you know like my
kids aren't crazy or anything they're
pretty mellow kids but it's there's like
this wall of noise that I walk into each
and every day when I go home and you
know I think it wasn't until I started
reading into noise and silence and
thinking about this documentary that I
realized how it really is affecting me
and how knowing it really is and how you
know stressful it makes me some of the
studies about noise clearly show that
even though that we're able to tune out
noise psychologically speaking our
bodies can't and so it's still affecting
us on like you know stress level all the
stress markers are going up so every
time of plane flies overhead for example
like we just kind of have habituated it
you know like it's as part of the
background but our bodies are reacting
to all these noises that are happening
around us in a negative way and so yeah
and I think I've become sensitive to
noise for sure yeah I think you
mentioned in the pitch video that our
world has become a lot noisier and what
what have you seen so far in terms how
that's happened yeah over the years you
know as technology grows and as we grow
more dependent on technology the world's
definitely become a lot noisier you know
when the Walkman came out that was like
this huge revolution in personal sound
devices right and everyone was walking
around with their headphones in their
ears and there's all kinds of studies
done about that but the most profound
thing I think about the the Walkman and
the advent of these sort of personal
sound devices is that we kind of use
that as a way to shield or drown out the
other sounds so at first you know before
before the Walkman and whatnot people
were complaining about City noises and
then the Walkman came along and we sort
of were able to drown that out for a
little bit and then came the ipod of
course not too long ago and everyone who
started using ipod was saying started
saying you know we're using the ipod to
kind of drown out
all the other digital sounds and
people's phones and whatnot and so it
was kind of like one layer on top of
another that we started adding on to the
layers and layers of sound just to kind
of distance ourselves more and so just
we're just surrounded immersed in noise
now I feel like and living in the
Greater Los Angeles easy living in the
Greater Los Angeles area what do you do
to escape from the noise ah a few places
here there are very few places to find
silence I feel like in Los Angeles um I
have not been able to find any place is
really that I can that I can find you
know Silas but you know I think it's
it's also a matter of finding science
it's also a matter of sort of a mental
state or state of mind it's when you
when you when you sort of find a flow in
your work for example or you focus in on
something and hone in on something very
specific where you sort of get lost in
something then you can experience kind
of a sense of silence where you're able
to really drown out the noise around you
but to define true silence i think is
nearly impossible anywhere the absence
of sound is just just about impossible
to find of course but you know their
parks of course there's i went to eaton
canyon just the other day which is a
pretty short hike into in this in the
mountains and there's a waterfall and
you know you can definitely gain a sense
of silence every once in a while there's
a helicopter hovering above my head and
what not and you know their moments of a
lot of noise but you know for the most
part there are places that we can go
like parks and whatnot where we can find
silence and like i said you can you can
you can find the sense and gain a sense
of silence in your work environment just
about anywhere if you're able to kind of
hone in on something and you know people
talk about meditation and mindfulness as
a way to silence as well
you